زياره الرئيس الفرنسيه ايمانويل ماكرون
للولايات المتحده قصتنا الثانيه صنفها
الاليزيه بالاستثنائيه فهي ثاني زياره
دوله يقوم بها مكرون لامريكا والاولى له
في عهد نظيره الرئيس
وصل مكروم برفقه زوجته بريجيت الى قاعده
اندروس الجويه في واشنطن والتي لا يطؤها
الا كبار الشخصيات وكانت في استقباله
نائبه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ويندي
شيرمان بدايه نشاط مكروه عشاء خاص او
بدايه نشاط مكروه وعشاء خاص مع بيضه
وزوجته اي ان اول لقاء ياخذ طبعا شخصيا
ويوفر لهما الفرصه للبحث في الملفات
الرئيسيه بعيدا عن الشكليات المفروضه جدول
الزياره رصدته لنا ريتا سليمان
[موسيقى]
من التوتر في العلاقات بين الجانبين بدا
الرئيس والفرنسيه مانويل ماكرون الثلاثاء
زياره الرسميه الى الولايات المتحده
تتناول العديد من الملفات ابرزها ازمه
اوكرانيا ومواجهه النفوذ الصيني فضلا عن
قضايا اقتصاديات الرئيس الامريكي جو بيد
ان اعد برنامج حافلا لمكرون يتضمن عشاء
عائليا خاصا كما سيحضى مكروم باستقبال
رسمي في البيت الابيض مع اطلاقي احدى و20
طلقه
واستعراض حرس الشرف وزياره لمقبرتي
الخميس واعد عشان رسميا الموسعا في البيت
الابيض بحضور المئات الاشخاص وسيعقد
الريسان بعد اجتماعهما مؤتمر صحافيا
مشتركا وعلى جدول الاعمال الرئيس الفرنسي
زياره الى الكونغرس يلتقي في خلالها اعضاء
الشيوخ والنواب وتنتهي زياره الرئيس
الفرنسي في مدينه نيو اويلز ذات الرمزيه
التاريخيه لفرنسا
اذا هي زياره استثنائيه لترميم الصداقه
التي تصدعت منذ تلك اللحظه في سبتمبر
العام الماضي حينما اعلنت امريكا تحالف
اوكس مع استراليا وبريطانيا ما اثرها غضب
فرنسا التي حرمت من عقد ضخم لبيع غواصات
الى كامبره واستبعد استبعدت كذلك من
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في منطقه المحيطين
الهادئ والهندي الاستراتيجيه مع دول شرق
اسيا لمجابهه النفوذ الصينيه المتنامي
وايضا لبناء قدره اقليميه على الصمود امام
التهديدات العابره للحدود لكن الشعره التي
قسمت ظهر العلاقه بينهما يبدو انها كانت
تداعيات الازمه الاوكرانيه التي حتما
ستتصدر اجنده اجتماع المكتب البيضاوي سواء
فيما يتعلق بالدعم العسكري او حتى في
الشقه التجاري المختلف عليه نقطه التباين
او التباعد ربما كانت على حد وصف مسؤولينا
سياسيين هي الاستغلال الامريكي الواضح لان
قطع الغ الروسيه عن دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
دفعها للهروله نحو مصادر غاز بديله اهمها
امريكا لكن الاخيره يبدو انها تتاجر
بغازها على حساب الدول الاوروبيه لانها
رفعت الاسعار بوجه القاره العجوز وجعلتها
على حد وصفهم خياليه ولا تصدر من صديق
حينها كان مكرون ناقد الاول او المعاتب
الاول لا الفرق لانه بدا وكانه يؤنب
امريكا والنرويج في احد تصريحاته كيف
تفعلون ذلك معنا بحق الصداقه
امريكا
[موسيقى]
اقامها في الاليزي حتى هم في خلالها على
البقاء في فرنسا وعدم الانتقال الى امريكا
التي بفعلتها هذه تستقطبهم لارضها ما
سيؤثر سلبا على قطاعات فرنسا في عده مجلات
كالسيارات الكهربائيه والبطاريات والطاقه
النظيفه حتى مكروه اكدال المدعوين الاسبوع
الماضي انه سيزور واشنطن ليدافع عن مصالح
باريس واوروبا ككل في مواجهه قانون خفض
التضخم وبعيدا عن الخلافات سيكون واجبا
مناقشه ما يصب في مصلحه الاوكرانيين اليس
كذلك مثل قرار نيته بتعزيز الوجود
العسكريه اضافه لاعلان واشنطن تعزيزه
جنودها في دول البلطيق ليبقى السؤال هل سى
يكتب للتحالف الذي يبدو متزعزع تاره
ومتوحدا تاره اخرى ان يصمد في وجه الشتاء
لمؤازره اوكرانيا
اذا زياره ليست عاديه كما لاحظنا بل انها
تحمل معاني اخرى في الرمزيه والتاريخ
والثقافه لان ماكرون سيخدمها في الثاني من
ديسمبر بعيدا عن العاصمه واشنطن ذاهبا الى
نيو اويلز التي لم يحالفه النصيب بان
يزورها في عهد الرئيس السابق ترامب ليصبح
اول زعيم فرنسيه زور هذه المدينه منذ عام
يسير مكرونه اذا على دربي رؤساء فرنسيين
سابقين اذ اتى الى ديارها لاول مره
شارلوغول في عام 1960 ثم فاليري
جيسكارستان واليوم يسجل مكرون نفسه كذلك
زعيم
فرنسيجارو ان زياره تهدف الى عرض بصمه
فرنسا الثقافيه والاجتماعيه في الولايات
المتحده لكون يورينز اكبر مدن ولايه
لويزيانا كانت مستعمره فرنسيه سابقه ويحن
اليها الفرنسيون بين الف ليله والاخرى فهي
مازال تفتخر باصولها الفرنسيه حتى بعد ان
قطعت فرنسا العلاقات وبعتها الى امريكا
حتى من يتجول في الشوارع ويحدث المواطنين
سيجد ان عدد منهم يحافظ على التقاليد
الثقافيه لفرنسا في المطاعم في الماكولات
في غيرها وصولا الى الاحتفال الباستيل وفي
عام
1803 عندما انتقلت بيورليانس بشكل دائم
الى الحكم بقي العديد من اسماء الشوارع
فرسنسيا مثل شوارع بيانفيل وايبارفيل
واحتفاء بذلك وتفكيرا لامريكا بان جزء
منها كان يوما فنسيا
يخطط مكرون بحسب له في جرو للاعلان عن
صندوق لتمويل تعليم الفرنسيه وليس انتهاء
بالمرور شوقا الى الحي الفرنسيه الذي يضجه
بالحياه رغم مبانيه السكنيه الاقدم في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه